joe biden's radical supreme court
nominee katanji jackson took to capitol
hill yesterday for the first day of her
confirmation hearings and republicans
kicked off the hearings by promising to
take the high road
and then most of the members of this
committee remember the confirmation
hearing of brett kavanaugh
one of the lowest moments in the history
of this committee
where democrats on this committee sat on
allegations didn't refer them to the fbi
didn't ask for investigations hid them
and then leaked them
against the wishes
of the complainant
and we began
a circus that featured spartacus moments
featured such nuts
as michael avenatti
whom cnn breathlessly for some months
described as a possible democratic
presidential candidate that's before
presumably he became a felon in recent
months
judge jackson i can assure you
that your hearing will feature none of
that
disgraceful behavior
senator cruz can assure her of that but
i cannot because as i have said many
times already
judge katanji jackson groped me at a
party back in the 80s pj was there and
squee was there and and judge catante
jackson was there and her manhandling of
me has caused tremendous trauma in my
life i i demand to see her seventh grade
yearbook and i have exactly as much
evidence against her as christine ford
and julie swetnick and michael avenatti
had against justice brett kavanaugh
but senate republicans have actually
unearthed some dirt on katanji jackson
that is significantly more damning
senate republicans have evidence that
judge jackson has a soft spot for some
of the worst child abusing criminals in
the country and that she thinks the
constitution is rotten to the core which
is a far bigger problem than any
grab-happy indiscretions katanji jackson
may or may not have perpetrated against
me as a teenager i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from colleen santos
who says get you someone who looks at
you the way michael looks when saying
fauci might retire i know that's true
you want to talk about love in your eyes
doe eyes that's that's the the sort of
spell that comes over me when fauci says
he might retire but there's that big
caveat because he says he might retire
unless kovid keeps going on and then he
says kovid's going to keep going on
which is why you really ought to check
out my series fauci unmasked doing
really really well on daily wire head on
over to dailywire.com to do that katanji
jackson probably will not be spiked as a
nominee because of what she did to me at
that party in georgetown in the 80s uh
that's fine look okay it's life isn't
fair all right i'm not surprised that
she won't be held to account for that
that horrible way she made me feel back
at that party with all that evidence
that i have of it but the senate
republicans are focusing on some other
indiscretions from uh justice katanji or
judge katanji jackson probably future
justice katanji jackson republican
senator josh hawley
has discovered while going through
judge jackson's
judicial history
that she's soft
on child pornography
here are i hope in the next couple of
days some of the cases
from your time on the on the court the
district court the federal district
court that i hope that we can talk about
let me just run through a few of them so
you know exactly which ones i mean
united states versus hawkins this was a
child pornography case where the
defendant distributed multiple images of
child porn possessed dozens more
including videos
the federal sentencing guidelines
recommended a sentence of 97 to 121
months in prison
prosecutors recommended 24 months in
prison
judge jackson gave the defendant three
months in prison as near as we can tell
all of judge jackson's case is dealing
with child pornography from her time on
the district court in which she had some
discretion to hand down a sentence
there's some other cases in which the
law she didn't have any discretion the
law bound the sentence that she had to
had to give and what concerns me and
i've been very candid about this is that
in every case in each of these seven
judge jackson handed down a lenient
sentence that was below what the federal
guidelines recommended and below what
prosecutors requested and so i think
there's a lot to talk about there and i
look forward to talking about it
this is a pretty good political
attack
when i say political attack i don't mean
it's an unfair political attack you know
the republicans attack the democrats the
democrats attack the republicans when
the democrats attack judge kavanaugh it
was over some completely made-up
nonsense from two lunatic women and
their dirtbag lawyer michael avenatti
when the republicans are attacking judge
jackson here it's over something real
which is that she went soft on criminals
not just any criminals sex criminals not
just any sex criminals child sex
criminals
criminals who committed sex offenses
against children now it wasn't child
rapists it was people who possessed and
in some cases transmitted child
pornography and some people on the right
shockingly have opened up this whole
debate over whether or not our
sentencing on child pornography is too
harsh that is besides the point guys
the the question is over judge jackson's
record when there were sentencing
guidelines on a particularly
heinous crime
she
cited toward the absolute lowest end of
the spectrum that she possibly could
especially at this moment where parents
issues or kids issues are the top of the
heap just look at what got glenn younkin
elected in virginia what was it it
wasn't cutting taxes it wasn't
immigration it was
crt and gender theory in schools just
look at what's been playing in florida
the parental rights in education bill
just look at these bills around the
country this is a pretty good
line
of attack against judge jackson but
people have debates you'll you'll know
sometimes see especially more on the
libertarian side of the right you'll see
people say oh
sentencing for porn even for child porn
is is too high if you're not producing
the stuff if you're not kidnapping the
child if you're not actually
performing the abuse yourself maybe it
should be lower okay fine
i think that's a crazy argument but
that's the argument to be had there's
something even frankly more concerning
about judge jackson's nomination than
her weakness on crime which is a which
is a big problem in america don't forget
we don't have an over-incarceration
problem in america we have an
under-incarceration problem we're too
soft on crime but the the more
concerning thing is that judge jackson
apparently supports
critical race theory
so this same issue the same issue of
indoctrination the same issue we saw
playing out in virginia we're seeing
this play out in jackson's nomination
there is an article in the daily wire
you can go read it biden's supreme court
pick championed advocates of critical
race theory in lectures and speeches
it's by tim pierce
apparently in a
in a lecture that that judge jackson
gave at the university of michigan law
school not 20 years ago not 10 years ago
two years ago in january of 2020
the speech was called black women
leaders in the civil rights movement era
and beyond
judge jackson said she took inspiration
from the works of derek bell derrick
bell is one of the creators of critical
race theory
it's derek bell kimberly crenshaw a few
other people
developed critical race theory critical
race theory is a
academic lens that views america as
fundamentally wrong broken bigoted evil
racist it's all a rigged system to
benefit white supremacy and to attack
black people
that's what crt says right down to our
economics our very economic system is
rooted in white supremacy so says
critical race theory well judge jackson
says she takes a lot of inspiration from
the people who invented critical race
theory it's not just that she said that
she supports the new york times's 1619
project
she referred to nicole hannah jones the
fabulous behind the 6019 project as a
quote acclaimed investigative journalist
and lauded this project the central
thesis of which was a complete lie the
central thesis of the 1619 project was
that the american revolution was fought
to protect slavery it's complete
nonsense even left-wing academic
historians debunked it even the new york
times eventually had to acknowledge that
it was a lie of course they they run the
story on page a1 they run the retraction
on page z 7000 and they still spent
millions of dollars to get this put into
school curricula all around the country
but jackson supports this kind of thing
this is this is more damning than going
light on child porn
it is because the libs go light on
virtually every crime other than the guy
in the horn hat walking into the capitol
on january 6th that's the worst crime in
the history of the world that person
needs to be sent to the hague and go
meet the guillotine but basically every
other crime violent crimes robbery
murder rape
hardcore child pornography all other
crimes you got to go really light on
because we've got a quote-unquote
over-incarceration problem so that it's
it's upsetting it's disconcerting for
for people who respect the rule of law
but that's to be expected from a liberal
judge
this is something we haven't seen before
we have not seen even democrat supreme
court nominees
who openly support critical race theory
who openly support the lies of the 1619
project who are saying that america is
evil that the constitution is rotten
this is the woman that joe biden has
selected to be the great defender and
interpreter of the constitution on the
bench this is the most radical supreme
court nominee
perhaps we have ever seen in american
history and she looks good and she talks
good and she's got all the good
credentials so people are pretending
that this is totally normal it's not we
have never seen radicalism like this
before it's enough to keep you tense and
keep you up at night which is why you
gotta go check out bowlin branch go to
bowlingbranch.com right now use promo
code michael these are the greatest
sheets i have ever slept on it's like
you are sleeping at a five-star resort
every single night i have been using
bowling brand sheets ever since my
bachelor days actually i got a set from
bowling branch as a freebie when
we
started doing this show
and
ever since that set i've said i don't
care whatever the price is get me more
of these i upgraded the size of my bed
first thing we had to go get bowling
brand sheets and the good thing for you
and for your wallet is that the prices
on bowling branch are unbelievable so
you're sleeping on the absolute highest
quality sheets you possibly can you get
that crisp experience every single night
but you're gonna save a lot of money
doing it
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt bowlingbranch.com get 15 off your
first set of sheets when you use promo
code michael at checkout b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com that's bowlin branch dot com
use promo code michael it seems that
everybody in biden world is either
radical or stupid say what you will
about katanji jackson the woman isn't
stupid she's got impeccable credentials
she presents herself very well she's
been in a very difficult field
and
apparently has has performed quite well
in it she's a radical
stupid people don't know who derek bell
is
right smart people don't know who derek
bell is because they spend their time on
more fruitful pursuits but stupid
leftists they don't know who invented
critical race theory they agree with all
of the precepts of critical race theory
because it's filtered down to them but
they don't read this stuff this woman
does
she is the radical side of of biden and
the democrats and the liberals
then there's the other side and this
brings us to
our vice president kamala harris who has
some really profound thoughts for your
tuesday morning
the governor and i and we were all
doing a tour of the library here
and um talking about the significance of
the passage of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time in terms of what we need to do to
lay these wires what we need to do to
create these jobs
and there is such great significance to
the passage of time when we think about
a day
in the life of our children
where is my bong
where did the producers put my i keep a
bong under my desk just so that when
kamala harris starts speaking i can
understand what she has to say and i
look under my desk and somebody took my
bong
now i mean this is a young company there
are a lot of people in their 20s here
i'm not surprised it went missing but
now i have no idea what kamala harris
was saying
the time you know man
you know man you ever think about time
and the passage of time man and the
significance of the passage of time and
then what she did
it's not even that she was talking like
a stoner so much as she was talking like
a student in class who's just stalling
for time because she doesn't know the
answer to the question
she'll say you know hey kamala what
happens in chapter four of war and peace
she and she didn't do the reading you
know and she'll say well
you know it really got me thinking about
time and the passage and the
significance and you know in the signa
do you ever think about the significance
of the past like she's writing an essay
and she's got a 1 000 word count minimum
that she's got to hit and she's only on
word 700 so she just keeps repeating the
same thing that's what kamala harris is
doing
you got people in the administration who
are radical you've got people in the
administration who are stupid and
generally if you've got those two
choices you probably favor the stupid
side of things because the radicals are
effective this is what worries me about
judge jackson's nomination
it's that she does know what she's doing
she knows exactly what she's doing and
she's probably going to be pretty good
at remaking our law and pushing a
radical leftist agenda from the bench
you see someone on the stupid side of
things not naming names well i will name
names joe biden joe biden would be the
the example of this par excellence no
one thinks joe biden is a genius he's
always been a
daughtering simpleton he's got air
blowing in between his ears and i think
a lot of people actually voted for him
because that made them feel more
comfortable that made them fear at peace
oh he's not a radical he's just kind of
a dumb guy who goes along with things
but the the end result
of the stupid people in politics on the
left is the radicalism
because they don't know anything so so
what does joe biden do he wakes up every
day he doesn't read derek bell he
doesn't read kimberly crenshaw he
doesn't know who these people are but he
licks his finger he puts it up in the
wind he figures out which way the wind
is blowing and then he just goes along
with that so that's how you get joe
biden who
does not give much thought to serious
matters of politics or culture or faith
or anything and he just goes along with
whatever's popular and because the
intellectuals on the left have totally
set the agenda because the critical race
theorists on the left have totally set
the agenda he just goes along with that
and now you've got the most radical
president that we've ever had not
because of some intrinsic radicalism of
joe biden but just because he has no
integrity and he doesn't have very much
intelligence and he has barely any
education and so he just goes along with
what smarter more effective people tell
him to do and he's the president so so
it works same thing goes with kamala
harris she doesn't know anything about
anything but she also doesn't have any
integrity or principles so she just goes
along with it
this is how
the passage of time is significant
because as time goes on and the left
becomes more radical
then the people who just blow in the
wind become more radical as well
now speaking of time some people are
about to get a lot of time behind bars
not child pornographers who go up before
judge jackson
but the the much worse miscreants the
much more dangerous insurrectionist
terrorists in america the people who
showed up to the capitol on january 6th
there's a guy
just to show you the kind of person
who is now having the book thrown at him
he's a guy named brady knowlton no
relation brady knowlton
entered the capitol at 2 35 p.m on
january 6th
he did not smash a window to get into
the capitol he did not use a crowbar he
just walked right into the rotunda he
walked right into the rotunda as cops
waved him in
he was he walked by cops as he was going
in and the cops kind of laughed they
said oh hey don't break anything you
know and whatever have a good time
he's a 40 year old law student he walks
into the capitol through the upper west
terrace doors
walked by several cops that we've got
we've got this on video footage
the cop said you can go in
just so long as you don't break anything
he didn't break anything and he left
after 18 minutes he was in there for 18
minutes
he now faces 20 years in prison
20 years in prison for walking into the
capitol after the cops told him it was
fine
and leaving in less than 20 minutes his
law degree has been withheld from him
airbnb has banned him and his wife from
using that from using those
accommodations
u.s customs and border protection
stripped his global entry access so he's
lost
one of his privileges when he
travels he's not on a no-fly list yet
the fbi arrested him the doj charged him
with obstruction of an official
proceeding entering a remaining
unrestricted building or grounds and
disorderly conduct in the capitol
building
they're accusing him of uh
breach and unlawful entry even though
the cops waved him in of conspiracy
planning or preparation
of
maps and diagrams materials devices are
used tools used to breach the capital
and this is just one of at least 800
people charged in the capital
insurrection coup d'etat now thankfully
mr knowlton has alan dershowitz as his
lawyer
alan dershowitz one of the best lawyers
in america harvard law professor for a
very long time lawyer to o.j got o.j
simpson off okay
o.j simpson did a lot more than mr
knowlton did he was lawyer for donald
trump defending the constitution during
trump's impeachment
there are a lot of these cases there are
a lot of these cases right now child
pornographers get off the hook
but
midwestern dads walking into the capitol
as the cops wave them in they get the
book thrown out and they get 20 years in
prison why because our ruling class is
punishing political dissidents we see
this overseas all the time we say
china punishes political dissidents and
puts them in jail on trumped-up charges
russia
punishes political dissidents and puts
them in jail on trumped-up charges
regimes in the middle east in africa yes
that's all true they do so do we
so do we
we are
and i don't say we're we are not doing
it the conservatives are not the ones
doing it it's the liberals who run the
government they run the entire power
structure of the united states
even when republicans win one house of
congress even when republicans sort of
kind of have a majority on the supreme
court even if republicans win the white
house
the democrats still run the bureaucracy
the administrative government they run
the media they run big tech they run all
of the real power centers and they
ruthlessly punish political dissidents
and they throw ordinary guys who get
waved in by cops who walk into the
people's house that his tax dollars pay
for and do nothing and then leave within
20 minutes
they throw them in prison for 20 years
if they can
this
brings us to ukraine
because there's a headline out of
ukraine that is really shocking people
who think that the war in ukraine is a
totally clear-cut very simple matter
and the story is that
vladimir zelinski the president of
ukraine who is heroically fighting
against the russian invasion and
standing up to vladimir putin and
refusing to back down so everyone in the
west loves him and they're saying he's
he's the great savior of western freedom
zielinski just banned opposition parties
from his country
wait a second that doesn't sound very
democratic that doesn't sound very
freedom that doesn't sound hold on what
do you mean uh president zielinski just
introduced just banned not even the
fringe opposition parties but ukraine's
main opposition party as well as as well
as 10 others as part of an anti-russia
crackdown
the four life party the left opposition
the progressive socialist party the
socialist party the socialists the union
of left forces the party of cherie the
opposition bloc our state and vol
volodymyr saldo block they've all been
banned by decree for at least as long as
martial law remains in place
this is obviously
a big knock to the argument that ukraine
is a liberal democratic country but
before you go blame zolensky just like i
say before you go
blame xi jinping or you go blame
vladimir putin before you go blaming
zolensky take a look at what we have
done
in the united states
you know
there's a lot of censorship there's a
lot of banning in america the clearest
example of this is when forget about the
elections for a second the clearest
example of this is when harry's razors
decided to attack me and try to cancel
me on twitter that's right you thought i
forgot i didn't one year ago today some
fake twitter account with two followers
who is almost certainly a democrat
operative comes out and
digs up some old clip of me
on candace owens's old show before she
was at the daily wire from years prior
and
it was a clip in which she said that men
are not women and i agreed with her and
they tagged harry's and harry's came on
my show they were only a sponsor after
that clip even aired and but harry's
came out
gave in to the pressure of the
two-person follower fake twitter account
and said that my my statements were
condemnable or awful were not in line
with their values and really
really attacked anyone our listeners
half of america at least that believes
that men
and women are different and called us
terrible people
and said after after our listeners had
been buying their product for a long
time and said yeah we hate you basically
saying we hate you guys and so
revenge is a dish best served cold we
have spent the the
ensuing year after this happened uh with
jeremy boring meticulously planning how
to create his own rival razor company at
the url i hate harrys.com check out the
trailer
[Music]
do you remember when there were two
genders and only one and a half of them
had to shave their mustaches
oh hi i'm jeremy boring ceo and god king
of the daily wire harry's razors used to
advertise on our shows they're a great
product and we were happy to do it
that's before some peon who works for me
went and said that boys are boys and
girls or girls and that was just too
much for harry's
they condemned our views views held by
millions of americans and virtually
every human who's walked the planet
until about 15 minutes ago as
inexcusable and they dropped their ads
from our network because of what they
called values misalignment you're damn
right our values are misaligned and it's
not just harry's either gillette razors
used to be the best a man could get
then they decided that men are too toxic
unless you're the kind of man who
teaches his daughter to shave her beard
if that makes sense to you keep buying
gillette
but if you've had enough of the woke
bullsh and you're tired of paying
companies like harry's and gillette to
hate you
and buy my new razor instead
[Music]
jeremy's razors yes they're real yes
they're fabulous
but jeremy you say you're a felt silver
fox with a salt and pepper beard that's
the envy of lesser men
you're damn right i am
and i want to be clear that shaving with
the jeremy's razor won't actually make
you look more like me
you're giving me power
could make you look more like this guy
though
and that's the most homoerotic moment
you'll ever get from a jeremy's razor
commercial
what kind of man shaves with a jeremy's
razor
i don't know how about cowboys
firefighters those guys have shot osama
bin laden
i mean no none of those guys have ever
even heard of a jeremy's razor but
but imagine how much more manly they'd
be if they had
[Applause]
right now you're probably wondering if
this whole thing is a joke
sure it is that doesn't mean it isn't
real or that it won't be the best shave
of your life
harry's razors doesn't want your
business i do
they seem to hate you and i well i can't
say that i love you but i don't mean you
any specific harm
our country is in trouble conservatives
are being canceled by hollywood the
media universities and now harry's
razors
stop giving your money to woke
corporations who don't think you deserve
their product
give it to me instead
head over to ihateharris.com and
pre-order your founders series razer and
shaving cream set today
yes it is a joke
yes it is real go to
when you want to save money not just on
your razors but on your travel you got
to go check out priceline right now go
to priceline.com since 1998 priceline
has been the best way for travelers to
book the trip they want at the price
they can afford priceline saves
consumers more than one billion dollars
every year so that their customers never
have to miss the moments that matter
with priceline you can save up to sixty
percent on your favorite hotels and you
can also get exclusive deals on rental
cars and flights when you save more you
can do more get more wow this view is
incredible more
another round of room service please
more
booyah i'm extending my vacation sorry
boss sorry ben
there are a few things that feel as good
as knowing that you saved money with the
discounts priceline offers you get that
feeling a lot because when you save more
you can enjoy more and do more at
priceline every trip is a big deal
priceline knows that every trip is a big
deal so when you're ready to book your
next one check out priceline.com for the
easiest way to get more wow more more
booyah just to name
a few out of it you know at the daily
wire we've started a lot of things a
razor company a movie company a lot of
things we also have our own publishing
wing called dw books we're proud to
publish books that actively fight the
left's monopoly on storytelling like
fiery but mostly peaceful the 2020 riots
and the gaslighting of america by julio
rosas which is going to pull back the
curtain on the blm riots that torched
our country after george floyd's death
roses was reporting from the ground he's
got first-hand experience uh to show you
exactly how dishonest the media were go
pre-order his book today at amazon that
is julio rosas go check out the book
we'll be right back with a lot more
ukraine president vladimir zelinsky has
banned opposition parties from the
country which throws a wrench into the
argument that ukraine is this pristine
perfect democracy and is single-handedly
fighting against autocracy all over the
world
in a way it does but but
actually zielinski might have his
reasons okay they have declared martial
law there because the country is at war
right now and the country is at war and
so
democracy perfect pristine democracy is
not going to exist right now there might
not be a government there might not be
much of a country left after this war
and so celensky's doing what he needs to
do and he's showing that perfect
pristine utopian democracy doesn't
really exist all the time we've done the
same thing here in america we've done
the same thing here
back in what was it 1918 in america
there was a socialist candidate for
president eugene debs he was fairly
popular actually and woodrow wilson
threw him into prison he threw him into
prison because he believed that the
socialist eugene debs was
to so far out of the mainstream of
american politics as to actually have
broken the law and he put him in prison
and would not let the man seriously
compete to become president
you don't need to go all the way back to
100 years ago you can go back to just a
couple of years ago
donald trump was never thrown in prison
but the left did their best to do it
they tried to impeach him twice and
remove him from office now they're using
the courts to try to arrest him to throw
him in prison for some trumped-up tax
charge or some financial crime or for
whatever they can they're trying to
punish their political opposition and
make it such that donald trump can never
run for president again they already
kicked him off of social media which is
the public square which is how we engage
in democratic politics in a
self-governing republic speech is
politics politics is speech if you take
away a person's ability to speak in the
public square where 90 of the
information that moves around our
country goes then you are taking a huge
huge chunk out of their ability to
compete in democratic politics which is
why when i point out
an inconvenient fact about ukraine
namely that it's not really a democracy
that
increasingly it's not particularly
liberal or democratic or that they're
banning opposition parties they'd
already done this in the past they had
banned opposition media they've arrested
journalists okay i'm not even saying
this as a criticism
i'm not even saying this i'm saying it
to give context when we're talking about
a regime in china
who's a geopolitical
foe of the united states when we talk
about the regime in russia geopolitical
foe of the united states when we talk
about
the regime in ukraine such as it is is
it on our side is it on russia's side is
it a buffer state
i think it is much more helpful to talk
about politics in
terms of practical goals than it is to
talk about pie in the sky democracy
versus autocracy freedom versus slavery
good versus evil
i'm not saying that those things don't
exist i'm not drawing a moral
equivalence between regimes on earth i'm
simply pointing out that when we want to
get into
actual statecraft actual statesmanship
how are we going to resolve this war in
ukraine
it's not going to be terribly helpful to
use these really overly simplistic
descriptions or caricatures of these
various countries
they sometimes apply
more clearly and sometimes less clearly
and in this conflict i don't think that
really the tweeting the changing your
profile picture to blue and yellow to
putting the little flag in your twitter
that's not going to do anything even
canceling
russia and pulling all the corporations
out of russia is that going to help i
don't think that's helped at all
even we've talked about this from the
beginning of the ukraine conflict
the sort of endless expansion of nato
and the european union has that helped
has that made the west stronger has that
made russia weaker has that made ukraine
stronger no i don't think it
accomplished any of those goals what is
wanted here is not simple condemnations
hashtag slacktivism what is wanted is
wisdom the chinese ambassador to the
united states was just invited on cbs's
sunday show on face the nation and it
was one of the saddest performances i've
ever seen not by the chinese ambassador
but by the cbs anchor because they
invite this guy on to
describe the situation which now
involves a lot more than just america
and russia and europe and ukraine it
involves china involves india
we're really talking about a potentially
global conflict and
every time this guy tried to make a a
statement an observation about what's
going on this anchor woman
cut him off and demanded that he condem
russia
russia amassed more than a hundred and
fifty thousand troops at china's border
well that's why
we wanted just to be clear
china
friendly good neighborly relations with
russia but you would recognize a good
friendly neighborly relationship put 150
000 troops on the border of a
neighboring country and then to send
those troops into that country
in those circumstances
why can't you condemn this as an
invasion
what
let's
don't be naive
condemnation
it sounds naive to say that's not an
invasion it doesn't solve the problem i
i would be surprised if russia
will back down by contamination
what is urgently will they back it down
if your president asks vladimir putin to
back down will your president ask
vladimir putin to back we have done so
they wrote and we will continue
condemnation
you know only doesn't help we need
wisdom we need
wisdom
we need courage and we need good
diplomacy
so while this babbling woman is is
running her mouth cutting him off he's
making a very good point the chinese
ambassador is saying don't be naive i
don't think that condemnation and she
cuts him off she won't even let him get
the point out she says well no but it's
you're being naive no you no we need to
condem why does it and he says lady god
condemnation
is not going to solve the war in ukraine
if condemnation we're going to solve the
war in ukraine the war in ukraine would
be over by now because everybody's
condemned russia everybody's condemned
putin not just the nations the the
companies the corporations have all
pulled out of russia we've got major
sanctions on russia not just ordinary
sanctions they sanctioned the central
bank they destroyed the economy they
destroyed the russian ruble and yet the
war keeps going on
the strategy of condemnation hasn't done
very much of anything that's the point
the chinese ambassador's making she says
well why won't your why won't your boss
why won't xi jinping tell putin to pull
out of ukraine
and the chinese ambassador said well
he's done that now he's probably done
that he's done that publicly but he
doesn't really mean it privately and
he's he's making exactly the same point
he's been making the whole time he says
lady
your slogans are not doing it maybe your
slogans maybe your condemnation maybe
you're changing your profile picture and
putting the little flag in your avatar
maybe that makes you feel better as you
watch the carnage unfold in ukraine but
it's not doing anything to stop the
carnage what is wanted now is wisdom and
diplomacy russia is winning the war
ukraine is losing the war it's not even
close
western propaganda is trying to convince
people that ukraine is winning the war
and they make up a bunch of bs stories
about the ghost of kiev and the snake
island people who told russia to go f
themselves and then they were all
blasted away and they make up a bunch of
stuff to try to win the propaganda war
ok well that's fine there's propaganda
in every war but we shouldn't believe
our own propaganda okay because we're
going to feel really good and really
indignant and we're going to feel so
wonderful about our condemnations until
ukraine doesn't exist anymore and then
we're all going to be surprised because
we believed our own hype and bs or
here's another strategy we could deal
with the reality on the ground frankly
this ties into what we were talking to
yesterday and what we've been talking to
for weeks about
about the transgender swimmer at the
ncaa championships it's what we're
talking about with the the radicalism in
our schools and and
the the way that that policies have been
presented around the country the way
we've talked about covet even the huge
chasm between the the narrative and
reality well if you're just dealing in
the fantasy you're not going to solve
any problems in reality so
i
i wish that the chinese ambassador had
been able to get more words out before
that babbling lady on cbs cut him off
because i think there's actually quite a
lot of wisdom in what he's saying if you
want to
stop the encroachments of russia
westward if you want to defend the
nation of ukraine if you don't even care
that much about ukraine but you want to
defend american
hegemony and you want to defend the
strength of the west then start dealing
in facts okay and maybe you won't feel
as good about that maybe you won't get
as many likes on facebook and twitter
but it will do a lot more to actually
help the situation on the ground
it's when you watch that man that
chinese ambassador to the u.s speaking
to that woman you can see the effects of
two kinds of education
two different education systems
the chinese education system which
didn't start out all that great but has
been rapidly improving because they're
focused on making their country much
stronger and their citizens much smarter
and then the american education system
which fills our kids heads with lies and
fantasies and talks about critical race
theory and how little five-year-old boys
can really be little girls all day and
talks about structural racism how
terrible america is and doesn't even
teach people basic manners like let your
guest finish before you interrupt him
and it's pathetic
because that chinese ambassador
seemed much smarter and much
wiser and much more in command of
himself and world affairs than that news
anchor did that's her job she's supposed
to be in command of those things she's a
tv host and a news anchor and yet she
she doesn't seem to know much about
anything i think it comes down to an
education problem and is it any wonder
sometimes i wonder
do
conservatives exaggerate the problems in
our schools my kid is not in school yet
i have not been in school for some years
now when i graduated college about 10
years ago so it's been a while since
i've been in schools are things really
as bad as we make them out to be and the
answer is yes
because we have videos from school board
meetings sometimes we have videos from
classrooms there was a school board
meeting in cherokee county georgia
where a mother stood up she was irate
because of the materials that were being
handed out to students in this school
and so she decided she said look you all
think it's fine for the kids to be
reading this obscene material let me
just read you some of this material and
the school board
ruled her out of order for reading
material that should not be heard
by anyone in the audience
excited
is
don't you find the irony in that
you're exactly saying exactly what i'm
telling you
you're giving it to me
there are children watching you can't
read that stuff yeah that's the point
guys i'm reading the material that you
are requiring our students to read and
then i'm reading it back to you and
you're saying don't read it back to me
the students might be listening
i love i love the absolute obliviousness
from the school board and the mother she
she can't contain herself anymore she
says are you do you hear yourselves do
you hear yourselves if material is too
obscene to be read at a meeting of the
school board
which is 99
or more
for adults
then the material is too obscene to be
read
to
the kids
to the children and the school board
members don't seem to process this
because the school board members aren't
really making the curriculum right the
curriculum is being created by radicals
and it is being pushed into the schools
by activists and then the school board
and the administrators and often even
the teachers really don't know anything
about it they don't know how to fight
back i bet those school board members
are just as shocked
as
as anyone to hear that that kind of
material is in the schools that's how
effective the left has been at taking
over our education system
that's how backwards everything has
gotten
it
there is no
neutrality here okay there is no
fairness we talk about we see it in in
ukraine right now banning all the
opposition parties
that's not fair that's not liberalism
that's not democracy there's no
neutrality there you see in a lot of
other worst regimes around the world
banning their opposition parties i think
the breaking news just came through that
vladimir putin just sentenced the main
opposition leader in russia who's not
even all that popular sentenced him to
another nine years in prison
but it's not just in those really bad
far away places that you see that you
see that in america too you see child
pornographers getting off the hook and
you see january 6 people going to prison
for 20 years you see blm people throwing
molotov cocktails at federal buildings
and they get a little slap on the wrist
if that
usually they just get released without
any question
and then you see conservatives being
punished you see
you see the clintons
the bidens making a boatload of money
through corruption not just in america
but overseas as well taking money and
bribes from some of the worst people in
the world and then
donald trump without any crime that i
can actually see the left point to they
they go in they bring in the southern
district of new york they try to get
this guy they try to prove
there's not
any perfect neutrality here okay we are
living in a real political regime that
really does have limits and and the
limits are moving very very far to the
left and if you are outside of those
limits the ruling class is going to come
for you
at that ncaa swimming championship the
other day the one where that hulking
dude beat all the little girls and
everyone had to applaud for this
that that was not
the end of the transgender activism
there
it was not just one confused kid showed
up and swam this has become a cause
celeb for
all of the transgender activists both
the people who are sexually confused and
their supporters so there was a woman
who showed up kelly j keane posey parker
who is a really terrific
activist anti-trans you know pro-woman
activist and she showed up and she asked
a giant hulking man in a dress not the
swimmer on the team just an older man
who was there asked him not to go into
the women's bathroom not to go into the
women's locker room and this man treated
kelly with absolute contempt
on the basis of the comfort and dignity
of girls and women i'm asking you and
telling you please do not lose women's
faces
my girls and the other women i am with
are very comfortable with being right
through well fortunately i'm not your
daughter and my daughter is also not
your daughter that's right and she would
still
she would feel very uncomfortable
right now
excuse
me here for a debate back to you right i
would like to i would ask you to please
call off your dog
i'm asking you of a mother do not use
female spaces
you are absolutely you're not a mother
you'll never and this man is there just
treating her excuse me hey call off your
dogs
hey call off your dogs treating her so
contemptuously and it's he's bigger than
her he's just visibly a man when you
hear these stories you think oh quit
picking on the sexually confused people
oh you know come on you mean old
feminist woman stop but then you look at
the reality and it's a big hulking dude
putting a woman in her place and saying
no i don't care if you want to use the
bathroom on your own i don't care i'm
going to use that bathroom now i don't
care if your daughter wants to be able
to change without my prying eyes my
sexually disturbed eyes looking at her
and me getting naked too with all of my
male body parts visible i don't i'm
gonna do it and you call off your dogs
and you shut your mouth and you let me
do it that's the reality of this
situation okay
the the chasm between the narrative and
the reality is pretty big the narrative
trans trans women are women look at that
guy if you're listening to this clip you
can at least hear it in his voice does
he sound like a woman to you does he
look like a woman to you no he's a big
dude he's a big dude who lived for 50
years as a man who fathered three
children and who now claims that he is a
mother
but he's not a mother he's a big hulking
dude and he's saying i'm going to go in
and i'm going to get naked
if i want to go to a locker room i'm
going to get naked in front of your
daughter and you have to deal with that
if you want to have a bathroom you go to
the bathroom by yourself too bad i'm
going to go into that bathroom too and
shut up there's nothing that's the
reality that's the sick reality of it a
lot very different than
the narrative
there's an amazing
there's an amazing contradiction that
we're seeing right now andrew garfield
the actor is ex is demonstrating this
contradiction he was asked if he should
be allowed to play a gay character
because he's not a gay guy so should he
be allowed to play a gay character we've
seen this controversy in recent years
should a
non-transgender person whatever that
means play a transgender person
should a non-asian person be able to
play an asian person what if they're
hispanic and they look kind of asian are
they should they be allowed oh maybe not
should
should you be able to play anybody
who has qualities that you do not have
and this is such a funny part of this
debate because the definition of being
an actor is that you pretend to be
someone that you're not
so if you tell actors they can't pretend
to be people that they're not then they
can't act anymore then you've just
gotten rid of acting acting as living
truthfully in imaginary circumstances
but you you need the imaginary
circumstances part so garfield says
quote
if we only allow people to be cast as
exactly who they are it'll be the death
of empathic imagination
so the two separate conversations have
to happen simultaneously meaning you
know talking about whether we should
have more movies with more diverse casts
and also should people be able to play
people that they're not
i'm not willing to support the death of
empathic imagination it's what we need
most as a culture and it's beautiful
it's the only thing that's going to save
us right now
so he's defending
imagination
and the crazy it didn't hit me until
andrew garfield put it this way
but what we are told is that
imaginary things
have to be real
we're being told that men who think
they're women we have to pretend that
they're actually women
that people with all sorts of disordered
delusions we have to indulge those
delusions we have to all play pretend
all the time
but real things have to be imaginary
so we're not you're not the actor the
the actor whose job it is to play
pretend is not allowed to play pretend
but the person living in real life has
to play pretend all the time
the man who thinks that he's a woman or
for whatever reason wants to present
himself as a woman we all need to go
along with that but if that same man
were cast in a movie he's not allowed to
play a woman
unless he's pretending to be a woman in
real life it's this
complete inver in what should really
happen is that imaginary things are
imaginary and real things are real we've
completely confused the two we are so
far
down the rabbit hole and we've got this
real obsession with sex i have to get to
this story before we go there's a
democrat activist down in florida her
name is kim mangone who has just put up
a giant billboard with democrat
pac money
and all that billboard says is gay
gay because you know how you're you
can't say gay in florida you're not
allowed to say gay
i mean that's not true there's no bill
that says you can't say gay the bill
they say says don't say gay doesn't even
say the word gay in it
but the democrats have created this
completely fictitious narrative that
you're not allowed to say gay in florida
now thanks to ron desantis so they spend
a lot of money on this billboard and
says gay
and she writes she goes how many of
these billboards do you want me to put
up in florida
my answer is a lot of them i am 100 in
favor of democrat activists wasting
their money on gay billboards that don't
say anything about candidates that will
not be popular that are opposing a bill
that is extremely popular in florida
and that is pushing a radical agenda
that has caused
americans of all stripes and all
affiliations to swing heavily to
conservatives in recent years
go for it give me the gay billboards
that finally we've got some political
compromise we agree put up those gay
billboards tell us exactly what you
believe democrats i want total clarity i
want the supreme court nominees saying
that they support critical race theory i
just come out and say it i want
democrats all over the country saying
they support hulking dudes going into
little girls locker rooms yup come out
and say it just tell me the truth
tell me and we'll believe it i want
democrats coming out against curriculum
transparency i want them telling parents
to go pound sand and then we're going to
see who wins in november i'm michael
nolis the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show internal
dissension royals disney as the mouse
house gets wildly political plus the
daily wear goes to war with harry's
razors and gillette that's today on the
benchmark show give it a listen